I mean just don't read them but would
you not do you not think that children
should read and they should get immersed
I think children I've got four kids from
30 to 11 right nearly 30 to 11. they
have
read a lot of books which have probably
challenged them scared them made them
laugh made them cry right I want them to
read stuff that actually brings out
emotions in them I don't want them
protected and cosited I don't want them
reading Roald Dahl and someone putting
little cotton wool over their face make
sure that little Johnny isn't upset it's
like no I want you to be challenged okay
would you let them read Prince Harry's
book without anything
my son's turning it'll be a drip like
that
I don't so I wouldn't let him understand
on Humanity grounds